I love classic movies Humphrey Bogart
Gregory Peck and all those old-timers in
other words my friend time was the 50s
my mother used to take us to the
shopping malls and the big stores I saw
this old-timers doing the elevators I
observed them checking them how they
drive it and that's how I learned I
picked up the vibes my name is Ruben
Pardo and I'm Nelly operator
professional my first day was August 14
1976 40 years seniority inside this
building
hello there we go
second floor ace gallery ace is the
place
and notice how I leveled it straight on
the money
professional up and down yeah I was born
to go up it now I learned the hard
punches of life real quickly I became a
paper boy at nine years old I started
with nickels dimes and quarters and I
woke myself up I'm the oldest of the
family and I was put on the streets to
work it was something that I had to do
because they needed my help
you're not gonna question your parents
I'm very proud of my brother and my two
sisters they graduated college and now
they got the education that I did not
have I did not mind making the sacrifice
when is your flesh and blood you do
anything something I love and I take my
family to restaurants in a new area you
have to look forward to something I
recommend that positive thinking
positive everything a chance of living a
little bit longer
hi ready okay okay it was so many people
and yet none of us have resumed
situation isn't that very powerful I
mean everybody has a story I'm watching
the life serving the public going up and
down I don't feel bored I'm here because
I want to as long as the elevator runs I
guarantee you that you will have me I
will be your number one to drive it
I'm right here in the first floor the
doors are open I'm ready for more